Who Would You cast to play characters
who've never even appeared in the movies
before and which actor proved just sassy
enough that he may even make a better
Harry than Daniel Radcliffe this is our
fantasy casting for the new Harry Potter
series The Boy Who Lived has some pretty
big shoes to fill he's gotta be heroic
but we'd love to see a sassier side to
Harry come out too considering he's a
lot sassier in the books than Daniel
Radcliffe came across in the movies
especially against a certain potions
teacher will be coming up on this list
next for that we're looking at Archie
Yates they don't even know I'm here not
only does he look the part but his role
as rebellious 10 year old Max Mercer in
home sweet home alone proves that he has
what it takes to make a great boy wizard
Severus Snape is a tricky one in the
beginning Seasons he's going to have to
be someone you can buy as a villain but
as the series goes on we're going to
have to see those moments of heroism in
him Alan Rickman definitely played the
role well which is better treatment than
our next book character on this list got
but for the HBO series we're
recommending Adam Driver he already
played a similar enough role as kylo Ren
in the Star Wars franchise when the
moment came I didn't hesitate and so we
can imagine him balancing out the light
and dark sides of Professor Snape well
do you remember peeves the Poltergeist
we wouldn't be surprised if you don't he
was a bit of a trickster Poltergeist who
appears in all seven of the books but
not a single one of the movies and we're
hoping he won't be ignored again seeing
as ignoring peeves would be about as
depressing as ignoring that subscribe
button would be for you so we'd
recommend you click on that in the
meantime we think the right actor would
be Andy Circus not only does he have the
comedic timing it takes for a role like
this but Andy has sort of made a name
for himself by acting through a motion
capture suit meaning that he'd be okay
with whatever special effects were
needed for the role but before we get
into peeves Harry's got across the
barrier to platform nine and three
quarters we're likely to see Molly
Weasley in season one in the first book
Molly was the one who taught Harry how
to reach the train although it would be
cool to see the series explore the
Weasley family a little earlier on in
the series too for the role of their
Stern yet lovable Mother we'd recommend
Catherine Tate who's made a name for
herself in comedic roles like Nelly on
the American version of the office oh
get out Skeleton Man her time on Doctor
Who proved that as much as she's
hilarious she can also carry herself
with the right amount of strength and
heart that the matriarch of the Weasley
family is going to need against some of
these upcoming villains for the HBO
series we're expecting to see one book
covered every season and if that is the
case then Professor Coral is going to be
a pretty major antagonist for season one
whirl needs to come across as shy and
unassuming up until we find out he's
been keeping our next entry on this list
under his hat it might be tempting to
choose an actor with more experience
playing villains but we think that
Martin Freeman would fly perfectly on
under the radar in this role he's
already played the reluctant hero in
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy and The
Hobbit we do not want any Adventures
here thank you not today and so we can
definitely see him bringing out an
interesting side to Professor quarrel
too Lord Voldemort is our ultimate big
bad from minute one afraid only of the
next entry on this list he's the
embodiment of all things cold and
calculating and as such we're gonna need
an actor who's really good at playing
villains and well Benedict Cumberbatch
has experience with the dark side in
both Star Trek and The Hobbit I just
Droid there and he has a general air of
sophistication about him that would
definitely suit Voldemort well we
imagine that he'd look the part so long
as HBO gives us some pretty cool special
effects makeup to make him look like a
snake as the Headmaster at Hogwarts
Albus Dumbledore wears a lot of hats
he's an old man with the heart of a
child and while he's incredibly loving
and nurturing towards his students he's
also devious and mysterious at the same
time basically we're looking for an
all-around amazing actor here someone
like Academy award-winning English actor
Michael Kane he's already taken on the
role of a mentor as Alfred in the Dark
Knight trilogy at this point I'll set
you up with a chimpanzee if it brought
you back to the world while being just
as skilled at comedy as our next entry
on this list it's hard to say if we'll
be seeing Arthur Weasley in the first
season he's a ghost kind of like our
next entry until the second book but as
we mentioned before it would be kinda
cool to see the series introduce the
Weasley family a little earlier and if
they do they'll be on the look out for
an actor with a long history in comedy
to handle the role of the Weasley's
muggle loving father someone with a wide
range as a performer considering how
intense this part is going to get later
on for that we suggest Stephen Merchant
whose Works range from the office to
Logan now peeves isn't the only one
haunting the halls of Hogwarts nearly
headless Nick is sure to be introduced
in the first season and we're hoping to
see them build up the Headless hunt in
season two Sir Nicholas is going to
require an actor who can deliver a big
personality which is why we suggest
Billy Connolly he has a long history in
comedy that would definitely come in
handy for the role of this Friendly
Ghost this entry proves as well as the
next just because a character has passed
on that doesn't mean they aren't still
important to the series as Harry's
deceased mother we're likely to only see
Lily Potter in flashbacks it would be
interesting to see the series go a
little bit more in depth with her
character and so we wanted to make sure
we cast an actress who could handle
Lily's fiery personality as it's
described in the books Karen Gillen
brought the heart on Guardians of the
Galaxy as nebula but she's also shown a
more heartfelt side in roles like Doctor
Who I don't know what it feels like I've
never had a baby before now she just
needs the perfect James Potter to act
across James Potter will probably be
relegated to flashbacks same as his wife
he's a bit of a jokester but takes
things too far when it comes to bullying
Snape he was also willing to lay down
his life to protect his wife and Harry
from Voldemort and fought for the
equality of all magical creatures
including half Giants like Hagrid so
we're talking about a pretty complicated
character here but we think Aaron
Taylor-Johnson can handle it his role as
Quicksilver proves his more heroic side
while his part in Kick-Ass shows a side
that's both darker and funnier we're
gonna need our keeper of keys and
grounds of Hogwarts for Hagrid you're
gonna need an actor who's sort of
physically imposing but at the same time
endearing in a sort of bumbling way Nick
Frost's role in Hot Fuzz proves that he
can handle bumbling and it didn't occur
to you to mention this before I couldn't
see his face could I not made of eyes
but he's always the heart of whatever
movie he's in
he said it's a reason it's going to be
hard to find someone to follow in the
footsteps of Maggie Smith McGonagall
needs to be Stern but she isn't like the
dursleys she isn't mean always meaning
the best for her students to get that
you're going to need to cast a pretty
strong actress someone like Michelle
Gomez who showed just how commanding she
can be as Lilith in the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina yet it's in her
comedy career that she really expresses
herself like them or not we're gonna
need to cast the dursleys right from
season one petunia is described in the
books as being sort of snooty as someone
whose resume includes roles like Queen
Anne on the favorite we think that
Olivia Coleman could handle the part
well she's also an incredibly versatile
actress who would be great for any
moment where they wanted to humanize
petunia a little more like the books do
which is something else we definitely
love to see Vernon dursley is sort of a
buffoon he doesn't think he is but to
any of us readers we see him for what he
truly is and when it came to Mark Addy's
role in King Baratheon on Game of
Thrones he was a bit of a buffoon nobody
could tell him because he was King but
we as the audience could see him for
what he was through the lens of Sean
Bean he can't even put a Man's armor on
him properly you're too fat for you
don't there are strange sort of
similarities between the roles plus with
roles such as Hercules and Atlantis he's
definitely large enough to prove
intimidating for poor little Harry
however the cast turned out we are
definitely excited to see how the new
HBO series turns out is there anything
in particular you're hoping will be
adapted from the books or any casting
choices you'd prefer we're all fans of
magic here so make sure to let us know
down in the comment section